the movie opens up with an introductory
screen that mentions the Europa mission
as the first attempt to send both male
and female astronauts into deep space a
group of six astronauts undertake a
mission funded by a private organization
to explore Jupiter's moon Europa in
search of potential Signs of Life the
team includes Commander William Shu
pilot Rosa Das Chief science officer
Daniel Luxembourg marine biology science
officer Kya petrona Junior engineer
James Corgan and chief engineer on Dre
block following this various Clips show
the crew of astronauts embarking on
their space journey as the scene
progresses the camera feeds begin to
distort and eventually cut out with the
last image being from Pilot Rose's
cockpit before turning to static on
Earth the CEO of Europa Venture Dr
Samantha anger is participating in an
interview she explains the mission
scenarios highlighting that the
spacecraft has surpassed all previous
records for human travel distance she
further describes that while she was on
a transatlantic flight she received the
news from the mission control that they
had lost communication with the Europa 1
Crew initially they thought it might be
a transmission delay but it had already
exceeded 15 hours of no signal inside
the spacecraft the crew assembles in the
central living area clearly disturbed by
James's absence a recorded video
confirms James's tragic death leaving
the entire crew in a state of distress
and emotional breakdown Kata expresses
concerns about notifying james' family
and discusses whether they should Pro
proceed with the mission the scene then
shifts to 19 months prior to the current
events marking the beginning of the
mission Europa Venture organizes a press
conference to announce the launch of
Europa 1 into space scientists confirm
the existence of subsurface Lakes on
Europa and the crew emphasizes the
connection between liquid and the
potential for Life additionally NASA
detects heat indicators in the konara
chaos area the entire team appears to be
thrilled about this significant Mission
the spacecraft is launched successfully
and the crew receives enthusiastic
Applause from mission control as they
pass beyond the moon's orbit while on
board James records a video providing an
overview of the ship's interior and
showcasing the tools they have on hand
he also discusses the effects of
weightlessness in space and captures the
excitement of the rest of the crew the
scene then cuts to the 21st month of the
mission and the crew is more than 500
million miles away from Earth in
contrast to the initial enthusiasm a
gloomy atmosphere has descended among
the crew William and Daniel are seen
talking about Andre's recovery
suggesting that he hasn't been doing
well lately probably due to James's
death as a result of this they decide to
bring him to the europa's surface rather
than leaving him alone in the Orbiter at
this point in time the spacecraft is
already in orbit around Jupiter seeing
their destination so close boosts the
crews morale to complete the mission as
they approach europa's orbit they split
up from the main spacecraft and proceed
to land on the icy surface however they
encounter radiation interference near
their planned Landing site due to this
they opt for an alternate spot which is
about 100 m away from the konara chaos
which was their preferred sight now
instead they have to land in the dingly
O Dumas back on Earth Dr anger gazes at
Jupiter in the sky holding on to hope
that the crew has successfully reached
the surface as she is unable to
communicate with them after taking a few
days to settle down at europa's surface
the crew members begin discussing their
strategy for collecting samples and
searching for signs of Life Daniel Point
set the challenge of obtaining the
desired samples since they did not land
where they were supposed to in response
Kya suggests that they investigate under
the ice since there is nothing else they
can do heeding her advice they start
drilling through the thick icy surface
using a robotic arm and then deploy a
remote underwater probe it appears that
acquiring the necessary data won't be so
easy in the midst of breaking through
the ice their spacecraft experiences a
couple of abrupt vibrations Daniel
attributes these to ice movements and
assures everyone that all as well as a
result they continue with the drilling
process anticipating more Shakes as the
temperature drops during the night time
the spacecraft under goes another
shaking episode while the rest of the
crew tries to identify the cause Andre
spots a flickering light outside the
ship he quickly grabs a camera to
capture it but unfortunately misses it
following this he rushes to his friends
and recounts his sighting of LED like
lights with a refraction about 100 m
from the ship the team then checks
various camera feeds but doesn't find
Visual Evidence how however when they
examined the Heat Signature data they
find out that the footage of Andre was
glitching due to radiation interference
coincidentally the footage glitches at
the exact same time when Andre started
to see the mysterious light this makes
Daniel believe that Andre might have
hallucinated the light and dismisses his
concern later that night Andre is unable
to sleep because of the mysterious event
hence he vows to uncover the truth
behind it Tom Delong is calling after
hours of drilling the machine finally
pierces the ice unveiling the first
Glimpse beneath europa's surface the
entire crew especially katata is a
struck and overwhelmed by this pristine
and unexplored Vista Kata being the
marine biologist estimates the ocean's
depth to be approximately 100 km they
set their course for the Target Zone
only to notice some unexpected thermal
activities in the vicinity while letting
the robot collect samples they hear
strange noises and suspect them to be
reverberations the thick ice layer above
protects anything from radiation but
even then they detect a radiation Spike
this makes Kata realize that it's
actually coming from below deeper into
the target Zone the team then prepares
to readjust course but as the radiation
Spike persists they see a flicker of
light and then something hits the probe
lens causing it to be smashed they lose
control of the probe just as they get
ready to extend its arm now the only way
to collect sufficient samples is a
Surface walk of 100 m to the Target Zone
frustrated Kata tries to persuade her
crew crew members to allow her to go
outside and gather the samples however
they refuse and begin to argue about the
dangers posed by Jupiter's radiation the
movie then takes us back to the sixth
month of the mission when James was
still alive on their way to Europa he is
seen recording his daily activities for
his family at one point the spaceship
gets struck by a solar storm exposing it
to a wave of radiation that damages
crucial components including
communication with Earth's control
center this explains why the image of
Rosa in the cockpit was the last image
received back on Earth in order to
inspect and fix the system Andre and
James dawned their space suits and set
out however there's a problem they must
return quickly due to limited oxygen
upon inspection they realized that the
communication panel has been fried so
they decide to open the circuit board
unfortunately during the operation a
piece of metal snaps and rips Andre's
suit causing him to lose oxygen seeing
this James rushes him to get to the
airlock just as they are about to enter
the airlock James notices the high
hydrazine has splattered all over his
suit due to the panel explosion this
chemical is so toxic that it can
contaminate the ship's air risking
everyone's lives the veteran Andre
attempts to save James by taking him out
of his suit but he blacks out from a
lack of oxygen knowing there is no hope
for himself James pushes Andre into the
airlock while propelling himself away
from the ship in his haste James forgets
to secure himself to the hall the ship
drifts away and James is left with only
minutes of oxygen William says that he
can no longer be rescued Because by the
time they get to him James will be lost
all William can do is apologize in his
final moments James thanks Andre for
trying to save him and tells William not
to be sorry as it was an accident he
then remembers his family bids them
goodbye and slowly asfixiate to death
back in the present the team debates the
possibility of a surface walk the crew
votes and katata is ultimately allowed
to go Andre and Rosa help her put on the
space suit while Daniel and William
decide to analyze data once on the
surface Kya is amazed to see the
mesmerizing view of Europa after some
time she sends back data from several
samples all are negative for life but
when she analyzes a subsurface specimen
she detects a unicellular organism like
algae this discovery brings great joy to
the crew members faces as their hard
work has paid off following this William
calls her back but Kata spots a glowing
area in the dark thinking that it might
be the one Andre saw earlier she
proceeds to investigate using her
Reserve oxygen katata turns off her
lights and walks closer to this one in
the meantime Daniel finds out that the
heat radiation levels are actually
moving with the light sensing the
imminent danger the crew advises her to
get back inside but before she can react
the ice beneath katata breaks through
causing her to slip through the tracker
they can see that katata is falling
through the ice when the crew checks her
helmet camera they see her terrified
face gazing at a blue light before her
connection is completely cut out in the
aftermath the crew suspects that it's a
complex organism that got triggered by
Kia's light and attacked her they then
decide to head back to Earth to report
their Discovery however as they proceed
to lift off they face some troubles Rosa
and William struggle to stabilize the
spacecraft due to engine malfunctions
the Lander stalls hurdling back towards
the surface as a consequence the ship
starts to fall from a height of 2,000 m
in A Brave move William leaves his seat
and releases the Water Shield to slow
down their descent he manages to save
the crew but unfortunately dies due to
the impact this time they land in the
original Landing Zone the place where
they were initially supposed to Andre
does a damage assessment and explains
that they're losing both heat and oxygen
as a result of which they'll soon freeze
before they asfixiate despite this Rosa
and Andre are determined to navigate
through the situation as the crew works
on figuring things out the ice starts
shifting causing the spacecraft to shake
violently Andre then announces that
it'll take two people to work outside
for a couple of hours to fix the engines
following this Andre and Daniel suit up
and venture outside to repair the
partially frozen fuel tank while Rosa
stays inside preparing the engines she
records a video and hopes that if they
don't make it the future explorers will
find her recordings she then connects
the recorder to the communication panel
meanwhile as Daniel opens the air lock
and takes his first step outside his
suit camera catches radiation
interference the ice suddenly shifts
causing the ship to shake again amidst
this chaos Daniel disappears Andre
reports rep to Rosa the Daniel was
surrounded by lights and the ice beneath
him cracked before he vanished after
losing four crew members Rosa and Andre
are the only survivors realizing that
the ship can't be repaired He suggests
an alternative fixing the communication
link to their mother's ship this however
requires salvaging parts from their life
support so that they will be able to
send their data to Earth Rosa steadies
herself to accept that they have to die
and proceeds as per his instructions
after a while Andre somehow manages to
reach the surface and starts
transferring parts from the life support
system to the communications panel
during this a blue luminescence is seen
lurking behind him under the ice the
light moves closer to Andre but he
manages to finish the job knowing that
her life is coming to an end Rosa
decides to open the airlock to uncover
the life form that claimed the crew's
lives before that she points the camera
behind her as the ship descends beneath
the ice crouching in the Pilot's seat
Rosa watches the ship filling with water
lights are seen moving under the surface
attached to some sort of tentacle the
final image captures an enormous
octopus-like bioluminescent creature
approaching the camera well be damned
it's the Kraken in the end Dr anger
states that their mission Europa 1 has
come full circle she explains how the
crew sacrificed their lives for each
other to keep the mission alive and to
push the discovery further the discovery
of the creature goes beyond their
wildest theoretical models highlighting
how our universe is stranger and more
More Alive than ever imagined the movie
ends with a group picture of the whole
team taken at the beginning of the
mission smiling and excited subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for
watching